[Music]  mr president  it's extremely serious there's been a  massive earthquake in northeastern japan  today  the fukushima daiichi nuclear power  plant is in critical condition  there's a make a tsunami warning  [Music]  if the power isn't restored core decay  meltdown  to prevent that it's necessary to  release some pressure through this  pipeline sir  someone must go inside the contaminated  reactor building  the radiation is high we'll choose we'll  go  if you're willing to volunteer you  should raise your hand  i'll go me too sir me too  those workers are risking their life  decide now  it could burst at any second  i'll stay to save my hometown even if i  have to die  [Music]  [Music]  you